christina grimmie same Lee is
disappointed in the Teen Choice Awards
the TCA sparked backlash after Christina
was completely omitted from the show it
keeps happening and it has to stop
Jessica Alba delivered a speech about
gun violence during Sunday's broadcast
and introduced several young family
members of recent victims tonight we
stand together with these teams United
and
and to this violence vans were outraged
Kristina's name was not only omitted
from the gun violence segment but she
also wasn't acknowledged after winning
the award for choice web star in the
music category Fox only confirmed
Kristina's win in a press release after
the ceremony outraged fans spoke out on
Twitter slamming the show and the
network one fan started a change.org
petition asking the Teen Choice Awards
and Fox to apologize for disrespecting
Christina a source close to Christina's
family tells ET that while they are glad
she won they're upset her name was not
mentioned at any point during the
two-hour broadcast quote it seems they
could have paid honor or tribute to her
in some way and that opportunity was
missed the fans have a right to be upset
Christina was shot and killed in June
while signing autographs after a concert
in Orlando